[Music]
that's Drake's friend right Johnny
football Johnny Manziel he was a clean
cut for me oh really he's sort of known
as a bad boy really he looks like a high
school bully yeah he just looks like a
little like oh I'm going not hahaha I
like guys that have moles like that on
their face look at sparkle in his eyes
he's got an exotic look to him that I
like he looks like he smells good a
little greasy on the hair it's like I
haven't showered in four years or I just
got out of the shower I don't fix that
and then you'll be good he just looks
like he skates by on his looks you know
James really looks like a franchise
franchise quarterback then he has the
but fumble and then we're all laughing
at him I'd like to see a picture of his
butt before I make an assessment I'm
gonna go with hi he's got you got a
certain Janice a qua you know it kind of
looks like you know if you really grow
your hair like that
[ __ ] this is Andrew Luck of which he has
none none I mean he would be smoking in
1850 yeah I don't know what's going on
in this region he's a better looking guy
to this picture shows I want to give
this guy a makeover from G's to gents
this little fella you know what if he
trimmed it a little bit and then cut his
hair he would be like a hundred times
sexier
he also has a little bit of chest hair
peeking out which is a hello he went to
Stanford he's smart you have that kind
of feel bad for the guys but like oh
yeah he's good-looking the hottest of
them uh no no yeah oh good you
objectively say it yeah they don't know
who Tom Brady is do you know I thought
Tom Brady was black people will hate on
because they'll say he's a cheater
cheated but what's that face that's so
pretty
are you probably know that he's hot I
can appreciate how he's objectively the
hottest person in this list but I don't
like Tom Brady Oh
Kaepernick my boy Kaepernick a lot of
girls will find him sexy he's all tatted
up I love him I don't even know his name
what's his name he looks like a greasy
bell pepper on a scale of 1 to
Kaepernick how hot is he I'd say he's
what his number is is a 7 Jesus if
you're up there send me
like this besides the whole light tattoo
thing except for his nipples like it's
like eyes immediately go to the nipples
more often well that's a good thing I
guess nipples are cool I'm gonna like
slide off my chair right now I'm so hot
I don't want to approve but I gotta go
with hot Manning ready you want to say
it on three one two three Hey so funny
Eli Manning is hotter and more
accomplished Peyton's like going to the
fair with like a girl and like make sure
you bring Eli and he's like but mom you
guys sucks and he's boring yeah I mean
he sort of looks like salmon pants and
boat shoes right yeah
Eli makes her a really bad dumb face
like worse than this though like that's
it that's a pretty dumb face that's the
face of Papa John's right there if you
went out to dinner with Eli who you just
talk about them once before yes Doug I
would be forward out of my mind but then
I'd be looking at I'm saying at least
he's hot if you hung out with Peyton you
would go all night and you like go from
dinner to a bar and then he'd take you
to his friend's really fun bar maybe
getting a little trouble with the police
if they were twins like I feel like he
got all the nutrients and he didn't
realize my QB I'm a Giants fan I love
this guy I kind of thought about him a
little bit to be honest like over Peyton
Manning I might play with my nipple ring
right now yeah definitely Peyton he
feels up those dad jeans I don't know
any like Latin folk named Peyton though
faithful there are a lot of good-looking
quarterbacks why are the pretty boys the
quarterback the coach like goes walks
through the high school and like hey hot
dude hey come play quarterback for me